[Music]
hello my name is warm dis judge it's a
long story however you can call me warm
or discharge or like my wife you can
call me big warm duty now don't be
fooled into thinking like I was that
this means over the warm heart of an
angel and our larger than average
appendage unfortunately it's more that
she thinks I'm a bit of a duck I need
two mini burgers anyway ten seconds in
and I'm already getting off-track so
let's get started this is a video of a
typical day in the crucible well for me
anyway the bills I'll be running is what
I like to call the splendiferous
aesthetic habitus okay looking badass
basically I'll be running around with a
bunch of gear that's primarily based
around the way it looks because in
destiny this is far more important than
any step that can be acquired obviously
if I'm really assess in the crystal end
up and so on to youtube montage a better
be looking my best as my late grandma
said to my dad immediately after
snapping his leg in half boy you better
match yourself upstairs and change your
underwear before I take you to hospital
what do people think so from this life
listen I figure she means it's all good
if you suck as long as you dress well
she had a lot of wisdom to give first
stop get them super sweet catch points
from there you can see me struggling
with the basic fundamentals of moving
and jumping I stop congratulate myself
and instead walk around this impossible
object and straight into my first death
with my palindrome in hand or as I like
to call it my noscope one-handed
boomstick I rush out to greet this we
wall off straight a little far from the
herd who would have seemed that his
magical vanishing jump confused him even
more than myself so with my spirits
lifted I decided to ignite my fiery
sticks of love and start handing them
out
to my surprise I even managed to stop
another fire he loves to handle it from
here it just cascades into a wild frenzy
uncontrolled shots grenades and the
occasional arm flail this is all while
compulsively reloading my gun regardless
of how many bullets to lift in the Meg
here you can see me pulling out the
official Crucible sniper the icebreaker
as we all very well know this is the
only sniper it's using in the Chris Paul
and all others paler comparison I pull
off a couple of very average body shot
kills and decide to retreat into this
cave this is where am it jack-o'-lantern
face
a clinton vase is my kryptonite for some
reason when encountering them i lose all
sense of skill and reason and russian
like i'm an ADHD child on sugar
after seeing them and again even just
for a split second before my teammates
gunned them down I lose all composure
forget how to shoot straight my
compulsive need to reload means I have
to toss over a sticky glob of diff tonk
jack-o'-lantern faces back so outcome
the fiery love sticks feeling quite
satisfied and on top of the world I head
off to share more love oh bugger
I miss at least two more clear head
shots on jack-o'-lantern face the poor
rather disappointingly settling for one
of his teammates instead while proving
to myself how bad my aim really is by
failing to shoot something that isn't
even moving he appears again however
this time I drop them quickly have I
just come over my cook tonight before I
can even ponder this yourself arrives he
goes super saiyan so like a man I run
fortunately my much braver teammate who
is obviously unaffected by the Jack
Lemmon face powers leads him into
submission I hang around closely to make
it seem like I was assisting with the
kill rather than let him see that I was
running away from better like a little
[ __ ] being the fear courteous player
that I am I could the Guardian in my
scope a warning shot before taking him
down shocked that actually killed him I
take a moment and then celebrate with
the love sticks
it's like I'm playing on easy mode the
enemy comes at me one by one I finish
this wee spree with a sticky glob of
funk all over this Guardian spinner die
hmm
they didn't come out right and then we
have hammer HQ I don't know what I did
to this guy maybe a ran over a schedule
punched a sister or something but he
just kept killing me
and there was nothing I could do about
it and again and again vailable
five minutes remaining zombie
neutralized
finally I got him and it was even
wildung a sword this is a good way to
finish things up so at the end of this
game was going to call it a night
son of a book thanks for watching if you
want to see more of this type of
[ __ ] gameplay and commentary give it
a like and leave a comment below hell
even if you didn't leave a comment
baguette on me your saltiness and you
makes me stronger peace